and out of this afternoon a Craig is on
camera with me and as you may have
gathered he does a little bit of a damp
start to our sunset Safari I'm a soaked
the jackals soaked
Craig is actually relatively dry back
there the rest of us are fairly the the
roof in the rain covers beautifully
designed of course to redirect all water
onto the driver on the basis that the
driver is waterproof where the equipment
is not so for whoever asked the question
about whether or not this is live well
if you needed any further proof than the
start of this afternoon Safari well I'm
afraid I cannot offer any further proof
than that hey we have a black back to
Jekyll which is a lovely sight to see in
South Africa the reason being that about
mine was it was about three years ago
there was a massive outbreak of rabies a
little wound their leg very comfortable
around that area there's a massive
outbreak of rabies which unfortunately
killed off a large portion of the jackal
population we've always had a couple a
pair of them around this area right up
at the sort of sandy patch firebreak
patch never a hundred percent sure if
it's the same ones that live at the
southern portion of sandy patch Road
really not a hundred percent convinced
but we've seen them every now and again
it's been a long time since I've seen
them personally and now we have one
sitting beautifully relaxed curled up
against a quarry Bush now that
fortunately the rain appears to have lit
up wasn't particularly hard rain it was
just a sort of a soaking drizzle it did
the job well enough and then departed
hopefully that means I can very soon
remove the voluminous poncho that I am
currently donning on the basis I figured
it would be quite bad for our TV show if
I got hypothermia
then he says that they just or she just
wants to give him or her a blanket I
know it looks as though it could use a
jolly good doggie blanket maybe just a
towel dry I imagine if it makes you feel
any better that the jackal would
probably look at you and sprint off into
the bushes with confusion the life of
luxury is not something that they know
but I do completely understand what you
mean it looks thoroughly damp and
miserable doesn't it soaking wet fur
unfortunately for the wild animals out
there there's no shelter to go to
there's not much they can do when it
rains except well be in the rain
essentially which is exactly what this
jackals doing is doing a magic
impression of a yoga pose actually it's
curling up tucking nose underneath the
it's high wonderful I'm gonna sit here
for just a little bit longer so you can
think of some questions if you have
questions on jackal so while you do that
thinking or if you go to David who is
out and about in the Mara hello everyone
and number one lots of apologies for all
the gremlins we have been having the
last few minutes but all seems to be
good and how nice to see Jack Ross with
Jamie I mean jocose are very small
compared to my huge big elephants that
they got now I'm sure most of you know
me and for those who may not have seen
me before my name is David and that has
not changed and Indian commercial is
bunga bunga good afternoon sir very
excited to have you on board today
welcome to tomorrow triumph I'm sure you
met Isaak before and we're gonna promise
a wonderful game today that's one of my
favorite boards and Bungay has been
doing one of the things he knows the
things I like all the animals they love
and number one for the big mammals
elephants for the birds he knows I love
the lilac breasted roller I didn't want
to thank you bengay because
also this morning boom guy caught me off
guard by showing me like a breasted
roller they could not see what I was
seeing was a buffalo right behind it
well a warm afternoon
I'm sure Isaac told you here and that is
justified by the movement of the ears of
those Elias the African elephants and
remember as much as omeka leave it up to
you your comments questions are always
more than welcome and that keeps us
going see that smoke are following the
mother very closely and I got a feeling
they are heading to that little Bush
there because it's pretty warm to be out
in the open and once they get there
they'll enjoy both a feed and some nice
shade because that's a good cover on
those big trees that you see in front
there it's always good I remember when
it you know in my village as much as the
MoMA toss did not come until the other
day we used to have a rough idea of how
warm it would be by looking at elephants
at a distance and you would say the
movie would flop would guess the more
warm or harder it is now this is my
friend lilac breasted roller my favorite
band as I said earlier and I've always
said it's the most celebrated band in
Africa the national bird of Kenya and
also the national bad maybe a few other
countries the one that I know for a fact
is Botswana and having her opening her
mouth again my guess is he's because of
how warm it is
I wish she's trying to you know cool off
we're seeing sometimes some animals like
crocodiles opening the mouth once pretty
one and she has no reason I have no
other reason that they can guess apart
from just you know cooling off by
opening her mouth well I like about the
rola vertical position you are and I'll
suggest possibly go look for some shade
but if you need to be there to get some
food why not you see how she's opening
her mouth my guess again
was pretty warm afternoon here tomorrow
and James is enjoying some primates on
top of a tree
so what we have here is the same troop
of baboons yes they are in the shade by
virtue of the fact that it's so cloudy
and there is no Sun but what we have
there is the baboons sitting in a brown
ivory tree that is in full fruit and
they are having a delicious delicious
meal and look at them
it couldn't be happier I don't know why
but there is the troop has sort of
wandered off towards the left I don't
know what on earth they're going to eat
that could be better than brown ivory
fruits like that one there it seems to
be the youngsters left behind the sort
of gangsters if you like it's always the
ones that lurk on the fringes that are
young males and young females I guess or
a gang of unruly teenagers
it's like you were David David is on
camera everybody it was an unruly
teenager at one stage about three years
ago
and what they do of course these baboons
not the unruly teenagers of which Dave
was one is that they get to they get to
these trees before they are the fruit is
completely ripe and so if you and I were
to try and eat what that baboons eating
we'd spit them out and reject them as
being either too hard or too sour and
probably definitely too taut the bar
boons don't mind that
boots on it because the baboons are
almost always even the clean that said
it does seem to be going for the
yellowest ones there's some very orange
ones they're just being quite selective
it's not just eating any old fruit it'll
be the most comfortable way to sit and
eat it is hilarious though if you look
dive just girls at one on top now it
keeps looking at us and saying what do
you want
I could watch these things all day long
there's a big chap look at him he's
having a go at the little one I suspect
that the big the big one
is one of the dominance so he set me a
big you know he's an adult
and the other one is a sub-adult and
they're probably both male which means
that the youngster best just stay out
the way because that big fella gets a
hold of him you probably also find the
big fella at the back there is low down
in the baboon troop hierarchy which is
why he's not with the rest of the troop
why he's hanging with the kids at the
back and what he'll do is take his
frustrations at being a lowly ranked
member of the troop out on the rest of
the troop
all righty I believe there are some more
issues with the juma feed I do apologize
for that let's get back across to Isaac
who has got some liens Namara yes I have
found the sausages if you haven't joined
us before this bride is very close to us
and a very close to our hearts it's
called the sausage tree pride sorry for
the genies that are getting into our
equipment for this sorry for the hitches
but we're back and we're alive this is
Safari life this is one of the old oh no
pack big males you can tell he's been
feeding very very very well it is as
fine specimen he's so fat I'm glad he
doesn't understand English otherwise I
would lose my job
he's so big he saw healthy and he is
alive and kicking
he is the dominant male together with
his brother who is I think somewhere in
the long grass that is another female
and I think it is kinky tail when I
arrived here she's the one that gave
away everybody else she was walking in
the long grass and I don't know why she
is the most experienced I don't know why
she's doing in the she's doing out there
in the open in the hot the hot Sun like
this energy is the most experienced she
should be somewhere there is another one
there you can see it slightly it's
breathing heavily I don't know which one
it is it could be one of the hard otters
so we are actually surrounded by the
sausage III pride in case you don't know
yesterday evening they managed to bring
down a fully grown buffalo and looks
like the male's joined in later in the
night and everybody looks to be here I
haven't seen everybody they seem to be
very hot and so they are lazing around
and they are lying around in the long
grass
so I haven't actually accounted for
everybody but easily I can say that is
at about six members here which means
the rest are all here I don't know if
kinky tail went back to the den where
she's given bath in case you don't know
about her story is that she is the
mother of the four females
Plus how there are five females she gave
bath about maybe a week ago and we
haven't seen the new Cubs the first time
since last time I saw her was yesterday
and they made the kill then she is here
and I think maybe she didn't go see the
Cubs it is normal for lionesses when
they feel comfortable to leave Cubs for
about two about 24 hours then going back
to give them a bit more milk and I think
right now maybe she is gaining some
energy gathering some energy so that she
can go to where they are and maybe spend
the whole night giving them the milk
that they need I don't know I don't know
how many they are and I would give all
of you some homework which is how many
do you think they will be how many I
think there will be three let's see how
many gets it correct at the end of the
next few coming weeks either David who's
gonna be coming here is my mate and also
I'll be coming here please keep us
updated on how many you think they are
and I'll tell you once I see them we'll
get you back to this girl she is rather
sleepy hopefully she can turn around and
I can tell you which one she is
sometimes it's the only way or the only
easy way to identify lions is to look at
the mammary glands
Jemma you asked me how long I think the
caucus will is gonna last
and also how long they feed on it well
as long as it's still fresh as long as
they still meet they'll stay on it as
much as possible what I think is
happening here is that if you got too
hot in the day and so they seek they
seek aid or seeking refuge under the
shade here and that's why they're here
they're going to go back but definitely
they have left guard there because I can
see the vultures on top of trees which
means they haven't fed so there is
somebody watching the caucus shortly we
will take you there
and when we come back maybe I will show
you it is if we zoom in there you will
see the vultures they are all in the
trees and they're all waiting for
whoever is watching the caucus to go
then they will come down so it means
there is still plenty of meat yeah while
I'm observing these guys I'll send you
to David who's got another lovely bird
right here in the Mara excellent either
coffee your Lions will be doing more or
show more activity or being more active
and from vultures now we come to a
totally different bad because sometimes
we grew vultures as predators very high
on the food chain but now we've got a
very spacious talk but the first thing I
pick from this talk she got her mouth
open do you hear me and a couple of
minutes ago we had my favorite Birds the
lilac breasted roller with a mouth open
and that justifies how warm it is in the
Mara
it's why I'm good today I read Bungay
yeah we had a cause I think he's saying
in some more rain maybe it'll help cool
off and this is asan doe build stock of
the stocks family I guess this is one of
the most beautiful
because of all the colors that you can
possibly see in search about them
looking at one two three four maybe four
different colors maybe five would isn't
that well they oh she's a vida always
found in water or wet areas swamps
little Springs by the side of rivers but
more so on water that is not moving
stands still water because the heat of
the dish is drawn to rely on how Phyllis
and from a distance pretty tricky to
tell males from females but we have
lunch if you get closer to them you'll
notice that smears got like brown eyes
you know well-done Bungay all the
females got yellow eyes let's see if
she's gonna turn very really to see them
in twos you'll see them in once unlike
certain birds that are monogamous turn
around would want to know what sex you
are as I said if she got yellow eyes
which maybe is pretty close to what I'm
thinking then it'll be a female and
anything brown it will be a male and
then males have little you know what to
cielos hanging down at the base of the
head yeah this is a yellow and yellow
yeah I'll guess is a gown it's one of
the tallest stocks we got around in
Africa definitely she's looking for some
crustaceans where she is and stocks in
general a very patient but very patient
and never in a rush to hunt or to look
for food so the only switch very
patiently until something moves via the
fish for warm of some sort
perfect light I don't know where that
would be where she is because of the
heat of the day yes it's true I mean I
you didn't know whether this stock might
have delivered that there comes with
Isaac of the sausage to pride I think
having done so well and because she
would say she delivered four cups with
Isaac then she definitely needs some
rest she definitely some rest and
because you can see how wide
she is Reuben opening her beak and
that's a clear indication of the warmth
and the cause of the patient when they
go hunting they always wait for any
movement in the water sometimes they may
use their feet to feel anything under
them if anything would meet you would
move they'll definitely feel a movement
and very quickly you see how long beak
they got and just dry bits right inside
and grab whatever it is haha yes talk
it's pretty one for you a and you can
notice he doesn't have any competition
where she is she is all alone and most
likely she'll be enjoying any food that
could be available there well she's
going to stay right there I don't see
her moving and my stock remains on the
ground but I think James Henry has birds
that like staying on top of trees like
the monkeys he had earlier
now we have got a bird that bird is an
idli
and that idli is a Wahlberg's idli now a
pail for Wahlberg's it is whether or not
this is the pale form from the north I
don't know they were sitting on nest
before I went on leave they're not there
anymore oh it could be part of the
couple that lives on twin Dan Road twin
Dan's Road which is not far from here
there are lovely eagles these pretty
quite small compared with many of the
others but they've just got a lovely
vibe about them because I think they
represent two things for me anyway they
may not represent this for you they
represent summer for me because they
arrive as one of the first arrivals in
August to tell us that spring is on the
way and they also have this kind of
mostly monogamous pair bond where they
come back home every year and what they
do I don't know what they do when
they're away if they Philander about the
place but I like the fact that they come
back to the same nest every year there's
something very comforting about that I
find many of you might think I'm talking
utter nonsense but I mean you probably
think that most of the time the Viet
miss Farish rock there David study about
that little bit of gunk in the sort of
top left-hand corner yeah that suppose
it is a relatively atmospheric yes
and you'll see that the feathers very
ruffled and that's because the bird the
Wahlberg's ego is a rather wit fires at
which you might ask yourself well it's
wet because it has been raining it has
not taken a bath nor has it had a shower
I will say the tur we almost didn't have
a shower before drive today everybody
because the water went down in the camp
but you'll be pleased to know that I did
have a shower
other than the well you'll be very
pleased to know that you won't be
smelling me throughout the drive David
smells like butterscotch and lemons I
know where I came up with that front all
right I don't think I can tell you
anything more about that well those
eagle I told you everything else they'd
lizards by the way they're big lizard
fan so leave just about anything but
lizards they're like
Foca dog Emma is that you trying to put
on a German accent or was this really
somebody called Volk a dog is it walk a
dog or have you just made it fork a dog
bulk a dog bulk a dog
bul K a dog a odd name
alright bulk o be be what be a LK a
velka bulk a dog bulk a dog right
whatever
Belka dog hello and your question is
this the Eagle that changes partners
well no not normally normally they don't
but there was great upheaval in the pale
yeah I'm okay thanks Dave great upheaval
in the pale form pair that lives quite
close to our camp this yet they normally
arrive back every year the two of them
set up in their nest lay an egg II
sometimes the eggy becomes an eagle II
other time eyes before that happens but
this year mrs. Wahlberg arrived back
with a new Lister a juvenile no list
for more burst and then we thought
we saw the oddness bear right behind him
and so well either she divorced the old
fellow and moved on to a younger model
or the old boy died somewhere on the
migration or up in you sort of there's
what south of the Sahel during the
course of the Northern Hemisphere summer
so yes normally bulk a dog they do stay
together
we are now going to go to thwart wha
well as I say I did he have rumors of
goo Chava on a kill so we'll try that
now Isaac is still sitting in the Maasai
Mara where else would he be unless he
was trespassing into the Serengeti and
he's with the sausages I have left the
comfort of the sleeping lions and now
heat with the reality of the truth this
is the circle of life we saw this guy
breathing and life yesterday afternoon
and this is all that is left of him
I'm sure there is allowing somewhere
here in the long grass that I haven't
picked up yest because there is nobody
feeding on him and there is still plenty
of meat a Lindo in the in the neck the
head the chest the legs there are still
very intact I'm sure there is a lion
somewhere here because the sanitary crew
are all parked in the best parking that
they have all waiting for the chance to
come for a nibble this is the most
common vulture the African white bat
vulture our commonest vulture and it's
also one of the most endangered bird
vulture in Africa they're all parked in
those trees telling me that definitely
there is a predator on the lookout
taking care of this caucus lions will
protect the caucus until they're sure
they have utilized everything over there
we have two different types of vultures
they want the right is the repels
Griffen Griffen and the one two to the
left are African white backed these are
two of our most common vultures in the
Masai Mara that is another African white
back torture
backdrop back there is the oh la la la
Syria escapement these guys don't
actually nest here they fly all the way
from the Western Corridor of the
Serengeti in the gold mountains and they
fly all the way here which is around 200
kilometers every morning and going back
in the evening to nest there we have a
few that actually nest here but not very
many all this we see here are here
because of these caucus yes that is the
beautiful backdrop of the Maasai Mara
Plains the reason I'm saying that you
know there is still plenty of meat it's
because I'm here the parrot are you
asking me if there is any hyenas I
haven't seen any so far and it does tell
me that maybe they got a beating maybe
they came and got just away because
sorry it's Kazakh yes I think they got
chased away by the Lions there Lions are
very protective protective of the Casaus
caucus if they think you know there is
still some meat it is starting to smell
a little bit that's why I'm packed quite
a distance all those white spots it
means every now and then there was a
lucky vulture that came and had a quick
bite a very tense quick bite and then
got away and those were the droppings
that eat the left it does tell me that
maybe it is one of the big males that's
taking care of this caucus because I
counted and I could account for all the
five females of the sausage tree pride
and so it tells me that maybe it is a
male I'll try and drive around here
enough hopefully I can pick him up and
then I'll go back to the females because
the smell it's a rather smelly and and
well I do that I'll send you all the way
to do my in greater Kruger where Jaime
has
something nice to show you oh the joys
of rotten meat on hot days certainly
carries an indelicate woof to it we
fortunately are able to counteract the
tales of horrendous smells with a very
delicate antelope standing on top of a
termite mound and so far she has been at
the most obliging carew that we've ever
had at the joy of filming because most
of the time being an antelope that
prefers dense vegetation when we stop
for kudu they're there for brief brief
periods and then they wonder off into
the thickets they don't exactly run but
they just prefer to be somewhere where
they're a bit more hidden she's posing
really really well for us on the top of
this termite mound doing exactly what
topi do as well which is using it to
stare out across the open area listen -
it's been a scary few days for the
various antelope out here particularly I
think for these kudu cause I think the
Lions were around this area not
yesterday but the night before last and
hunting in this windy rainy weather they
were could've tracks
absolutely everywhere you can see her
staring out ruminating Chris and I were
talking we think that husana caught a
kudu yesterday in that block that's
where all of us vultures were and we
think that he probably lost it to the
hyenas we couldn't quite figure it out
though it was all just guesswork and
supposition Emma thinks that perhaps
it's the reason why this could he was so
still she is having an existential
crisis after the death of one of her
herd members presumably no I think she's
just ruminating I'm not sure could who
have existential crises
there's the plural of crisis Crisis
crisis right
both will go with both for what is what
is grass what is life why am i ears so
big why couldn't I be born a lion or
Leopard I'm not sure what sort of
existential crisis I could who would
have she was like she might be pregnant
there's definitely a little bulge to her
Billy Tristan I think is has seen one
tiny baby kudu I haven't yet and some of
those things that I quite look forward
to I really look forward to actually at
this time of year little baby kudu with
their long long limbs and absurdly large
ears with because she's so damp it looks
like that it looks like those white
stripes have washed down her sides right
we really do have to focus on finding
something I'm not sure what the
something is I'm hoping it's a hyena den
meanwhile off to Lauren and the
romancing hippo presumably of before
sock Dam I have indeed found something
and it is almost becoming a guarantee
these days there's no point in driving
past before so damn if you're not gonna
say hello to Scuba Steve and snorkel
Sarah so both Sam and I were just
talking about how it would be really
lovely to come by and see them doing
something other than well what exactly
they are doing right now so we did get a
yawn or two from Sarah who we believed
to be the one on the right hand side and
if you actually look at them closely
there is quite a size difference between
the two of them especially within the
head so the males are always much bigger
than the females
so Scuba Steve is on the left and
snorkel Sierra is on the right and she
did sort of get out and I think she gave
us about three yawns but of course
the minute we go live she decides to
turn her back actually and completely
face the other way so I wonder if they
do do much with their lives because it
appears to me that they are the version
over the hippo version of the couch
potatoes they really do not do anything
other than chill in the middle of before
them now when you go out in the morning
the sunrise Safari you see hippo tracks
everywhere around here
everywhere so obviously at nighttime
they do wonder they do explore but
during the day they just chill I wonder
what you could call the couch potato
version for a head pool be interesting
to hear some ideas on that one
Nina's scene she's camera shy yes hmm
that was a little flirtatious side but
yes I do believe she is camera shy she's
probably not too happy that we're here
and interrupts in their naptime their
afternoon nap so we just thought we
would say hello to them because there's
absolutely no point in just driving on
by and not checking up on two of our
lovely characters we have here are you
gonna give us a yawn Steve obviously not
and of course the minute you leave Steve
standing up and going back down against
that's the most we've seen him do so you
can see they actually can stand on the
bottom here that's some standing so when
you see them sort of just looking like
they're completely submerged you're
obviously just laying flat on the bottom
or they've maybe got their legs bein so
that isn't fully standing up in the
board are not completely submerged and
of course their Latin name is
hippopotamus amphibious
and I'm phibian meaning to life easy so
we do require the land and the water but
in cancer ahead porn land would be a
completely different experience to
encountering one sitting in the water oh
yeh sab says thank you Sarah you give us
exactly what we were hoping for a
wonderful look inside your huge mouth
now that was probably most likely Becky
on hippos do sort of do that it's a
territorial display and I don't believe
that act was very territorial that's
maybe just either a yawn or telling us
please go away you know you're talking
too much
but what a mouth that was and you could
see those huge not very clean teeth
inside the mouth so we believe these
hippos and let them go about they are
busy daily life but for now we're gonna
send you up to David and Amara
well then Lauren and insolently I'm also
very close to some water body that we
call the Mara River very close to the
famous Mara River and this is where or
the migration almost of the wildebeests
will always close either when they come
into this side off the Mara Mara is
divided into two we have what we call
tomorrow triangle and the main ma we are
always best in the Mara triangle and
what you see is very famous mara Arriba
and many times you come to any water
body in Africa chances are you'll always
see something moving or something
drinking as we say water is life and
maybe even game it have sports it's
maybe a crocodile there and yes rockman
game okay looks like one and quiets
there but if you're Bunga if you go to
the left there it could be one that can
only see the back sorry to make you move
in such a tight angle but I've always
known you are capable of getting
anything there's an Egret right there
and if you go further to the left
there's one croc then if you go further
left and if you sing little bit keep
going yes that was very sneaky and it
lied to me and that's what you call rock
looking I know that's what they like all
them are LA and this one o'clock they
are sitting quite difficult angle for
you but well done Bungay I've always
trusted you you can always get anything
for me and for the viewers and let's
croc now that's what you call the nail
crop now that's right underwater there
so in that position and that's how the
chance or the weight for any animals
that should be crossing and not
necessarily the wildebeest because most
of the will be gone now back to Tanzania
I'm talking about the Serengeti National
Park and I think all the carving or the
dropping of the young ones is done but
once they're gone with
other animals that you'd come for a
drink of in porous or Thomson result or
you know a few zebras will remain around
and if you look at that croc just like
the sneaky one that we saw earlier the
rocks and crocodiles almost look the
same in the water and these animals when
they come for a drink they never tell
the difference between the two and
crocodiles have been known to hide in
the water I'll stay in the water with
the eyes open and you can see what is
happening in the outside world there's a
stock they're very different from the
one who is to be formed and this is
called the yellow-billed stock they have
a commonality always you find them in
places with water no she's doing she was
a very different a little different
feeding habit with the sunder build
stock that twist so before she moves
very slowly because on her feet she got
like sensors or fillers and that's what
she'll use to sense any prey or any food
under the water you can see the
reflection of herself in the water and
also using Harbach to disturb the soil
or the base of the river and that way
anything moves she'll either very
quickly spirit with a big you just grab
it depending on the situation this is so
cool I agree with um infinite control
and since it's pretty cool and above all
I'm looking at howl affection control
you like to know whether he got to the
river at night no we don't because it's
very difficult to see anything and
anything would see in the river would be
like say hippos like now and cambot
night they'll definitely come out to go
and feed hippos who will remain in the
water the better part of the day and
anything six seven o'clock out legal
feeling but should we come we'll always
come and chance see or and Crocs because
definitely the Crocs will not leave
water we have seen once a royal Crocs on
the base on the bank rather of the river
because it's pretty cool because you
know being reptiles in the are
cold-blooded and they might try and
capture the last heat or warmth of the
day how they happen so that one is just
going to rest there so we're gonna move
on and I was chanting to see we could
get anything crossing the river and the
water level to me looks quite low and
the rains when they stopped because
where this river start or the source of
this river is an area that you called
mouth the mouth forest so it's not
raining anymore so the water levels in
the river half gone quite so I think
Isaac is doing better than me because he
got his lines he hasn't left them yet
it got too smelly for me and I've had
just had a very good lunch I didn't want
to lose it
so I decided to leave the Buffalo and
whoever is looking after it and decided
to come down to where all these girls
are waiting for the temperatures to drop
so that they can go back and finish off
what is left in that carcass of the
Buffalo this is a one of the old Ono
Piatt mills he hasn't moved all we know
he is alive but he hasn't no reason his
head he has in reason his leg or
anything all I can see is that panting
and actually quite you know previously
because he is very hot from you know
trying to digest whatever he ate which
is the Buffalo and at the same time
trying to lose excess heat Lions luck
sweat glands on the skins so all excess
heat is lost through the mouth a brief
history about this beautiful pride of
lions is that they have five females to
males three
no actually five months old cubs and
about four weeks old Cubs in total at
the moment they are about fourteen and
they are going to get more because there
is two females that we think kinky tail
has given birth we haven't seen the Cubs
and then there's another one that quite
soon she's gonna get be giving birth so
the pride is going to be very big and
because they depend on Buffalo to us the
in us their livelihood here I think
they're going to get better at that
because the buffaloes are becoming less
and less and actually they have
eliminated almost all the weak ones and
the ones I've seen today are actually
quite healthy the one yesterday I would
say you know he was he was big he was a
bit old but it took about five hours for
them
to bring him down so I wonder how often
they will be killing because they will
need more food as the pride get bigger
this is one of the females you can tell
she's being a little bit active than the
others
she's rolling around and I'm hoping
maybe later on in the evening they will
be able to take us to where the Cubs are
I know where the four Cubs are but I
don't want to go there without the
mother because I know for sure they are
hidden so they won't come out there's no
need to go there we wait until maybe the
figure goes there then I'll go and show
them to you this long grass is ideal for
these great cuts because it's good for
ambushing it's good for keeping off you
know other you know animals from
detecting where they are so it C is
perfect it is perfect for these lives
yes these guys are still quite lazy over
here I'm hoping they're gonna get active
so let me send you to Jamie who's
looking for the same kind Thank You
Isaac thank you very much indeed we
could do with all the luck of being sent
our side look how solid there has a way
of showing up for TV shows it's as
though he knows that we we need him he
arrives at our time of need but what I'm
doing is I'm not even trying to search
for her Sanne the tracking now today is
going to be next to impossible so I'm
just driving around hoping that I'm
going to bump into something might get
lucky who can worry might decide all his
scent marks have been washed away but
really what I'm doing is looking for a
concentration of hyena tracks going
backwards and forwards from an area we
the only way we're gonna find this day
and I think is either with a drone a
drag mark of a kill because of course
Corki will take food back to the den as
we know or following Corki or pretty
into the den itself it's moved from
little Gary I don't know if it's moved
back here I checked the dens last night
during the rehearsal ever ever knows why
laughing I had one of those moments
where I I was going into an ad break it
was my first segment in this practice
run and you know we get counted into an
ad break and we get it we have to hit it
fairly on the mark because otherwise it
doesn't fit in with the ads for TV
so I about 40 seconds to go I talked to
my own spit and I was trying desperately
to not cough but you know when you get
that kind of tickle that the more you
talk the more it tickles the more you
cough and I couldn't contain us and then
I started to giggle I just lost it
because of the hilarity of the situation
hit me at around about 15 seconds to go
at which point Emma then started to
giggle as she was giving me the
countdown
and subdued in just for good measure so
all three of us were giggling away
frantically while if his trying to count
me in to the practice ad break sort of
like ten nine it was very funny
we were we were proper giggling Gertie's
that's what's known as corpsing we
corpse by corpse I was the one who was
doing all the talking
a corpse corpse quite spectacularly we
did I haven't corpse like that in a very
long time no weird turn of phrase where
does that come from is it I'm sorry that
your mustard it was hilarious maybe one
day you are no sip didn't record it he
said he he experienced he he was he
thought it was hilarious but after the
expressed deep regrets that he hadn't
recorded it but maybe one day it'll make
it into a a blooper reel Emma says that
corpsing comes from Shakespearean plays
or she thinks I Nina tracks knew no
hyena tracks her leopard tracks ah Emma
said that it is on three place so you
never know it might make it into one of
our blooper reels one day me trying to
get the words we'll see you after the
break out of while I was giggling
hysterically and I started to laugh so
hard that hard that I started to cry
as her anus so everything about it was
just exuded professionalism
no definitely not idea when the ad
breaks only two minutes long and Emma
wanted to come out with me she
eventually abandoned me went to someone
else so hey I hope that makes an
appearance one day so you can watch it
we watched it twice this morning in
review
I have no animals for you
there's no tracks there's no hyena
tracks I really thought I'd get lucky
here I haven't got lucky oh I have to
admit it drew my attention earlier this
afternoon but I didn't comment on it
perhaps it James perhaps James is more
insight into the brightness of his
jackets this afternoon we don't want to
talk about my jacket what we will talk
about is this capris we have Fugit can
you get the bird now this is not why
we've stopped here everybody we've
stopped here because we've found a kill
that Carver made now she's not at the
kill as far as we can tell we will go
back there and have a look but I'm
wondering if perhaps she hasn't gone to
fetch her little babies and that would
be special she's got two cubs apparently
there'd be roughly three months old now
which means they're about the right age
to come to a kill
those are writs as helmet strikes giving
that eagle a bit of a hard time and it
is a Wahlberg's Eagle and I wonder if
it's not a Wahlberg's Eagle from this
year I wonder if it's not a new one you
see how it has got that mottled sort of
feathering there it says helmet rights
are really quite beautiful when they sit
still
it's quite gorgeous David this is not in
the background you can hear the
diederich schuylkill I think these are
beautiful birds and I just think that
that sky behind is so atmospheric oh and
Haupt rush forward to get another view I
will take you to the kill as well
promised at some stage
oh they're too maybe they don't babies
they're both very odd colors though you
see them both
how's that one of them is just flown off
no gosh I parked you beautifully havena
what a floor fan I've had an almost
completely white head that's a gray
headed Bush right you can hear
very nice
a sky is fairly ominous as many of you
are commenting but it's not too bad is
quite atmospheric I think the
combination of the bird the green of
these false marula trees and the eagle
just wonderful oh I must just tell you I
told you a lie earlier by mistake the
balloons that we were watching were not
in fact sitting in a brown ivory tree we
were sitting quite far away from it so
that's my excuse it was in fact a false
Melinda tree like these ones here and to
apologize for lying to my promise you it
wasn't on purpose
all right let's again see if we can find
the limit kill
it's just done yeah we did find a ditch
let's get back to David and look at his
giraffe while I fix David's back
thank you James
and a world back said to be free but
watch and we got a huge male draft just
striding very steadily even very
majestically in the mara triangle or in
the morrow savanna wonderful light and
has only been said when giraffes walk
and they seem to move two legs of one
side at the same time
Kaneesha has thought Bungay see that Chi
the symptom Chi you know and I've always
you know Said's myself I think almost
may do that but I think it's more
conspicuous to the drops it's more clear
he is crossing the road and finding out
maybe asking to view us why do they
think that's particularly rough crossed
the road and my guess is for a few
reasons
either to go catch up with other
giraffes on the other side or for some
other reasons I would not know why he
crossed the road I'm sure the viewers
can tell us why this Masai giraffe
crossed the road hitchhiking on him few
oxpeckers you can see some birds right
on his backbone up and down on the
ground and trying to weave through the
main on her neck Thank You Bungay for
showing us that and those are the up
speakers they could either be yellow
bear dog speak has a red bill dog
speakers and they could very sharp beaks
and they use the BIG's like scissors
sometimes they tend to cut the far and
access any ticks or mites on this huge
or tallest mammals that we got in the
world
on the other side we've got some impalas
and we can in wartime would know what I
sell presents my personality well let me
think I don't have to think either I'll
say an elephant because I love elephants
are weakening I would say for me anytime
the elephant I don't know what Bungay
would say about that Bungay what do you
think what's the animal that represents
your personality Bungay rhino we joined
you disabled gay well I were kidding my
cameraman yup engage my camera
registered a and VIN gaze his array no
I'm not sure why he sees a rhino I'll
ask him when he got back to the camp
later today why he thinks should be
right now but for me I reckoning I would
say any time an elephant one very
intelligent animals and the things they
do show a lot of empathy in them a lot
of emotions in them a lot of you know
intelligence on the stage very bright
big animals and they let human beings in
so many ways you know the times when it
gets very dry and rivers dry you know
Springs or any water points will dry
elephants have been known to dig water
and up to them drinking they'll make
sure or other animals benefit and crews
on the other side near that bush we have
lots of other antelopes mark has very
good Christian and like to with the
giraffes are strictly vegetarian I would
say yes I mean I haven't seen ruff eat
anything else but markers are likely to
know you to know there we have you know
for the vegetarian so for the Hobby boss
we divided them into two we divide them
into browsers and to grazers like those
zebras you see there Marcus we would
call them grazers they tend basically to
deal on the cross not sure where they're
heading for the head into the direction
of the Mara River no markers looking at
giraffes durasuite : browsers browsers
in the sense that they tend to browse
the tension eat anything on top nothing
on the ground as much as we see
sometimes giraffe spreading the legs out
and feeding on the ground but not to
grass entirely but any small
plants it is more hops they get they'll
be picking the leaves but in general
you'll always see them each country so
I'd say in short giraffes 100%
vegetarians all right Marcus that makes
sense what won't do now is to move this
small little baby zebra here I don't
know why she's not joining the rest
she's pretty young Rosaleen good
question was how the fastest drops can
run difficult question I might give very
quick hands and say maybe 40 50
kilometers an hour but my other concern
with that kind of speed loss really I'm
giving you is at watch train will let's
do that you know at what kind of
vegetation with a giraffe cover that
speed may be per kilometer so it's very
vague on some giving you because unlike
other animals that we have been able to
domesticate for example resilient
cheetahs they have been domesticated and
that will put in open flat areas and
given a chase and roughly you can have
an idea on the speed but nobody has been
able to domesticate giraffes so it
becomes very difficult to give a speed
but anything 50 60 kilometers an hour I
would say it should make sense as a
speed of a giraffe
but again Hills the rocks the mountains
and other encumbrance on their way as
they iran well I think we've been
looking for highness this afternoon as
much as a hunts not say that's my plan
but I think Lauren could be having some
or one
I gotta high you know and it's pretty it
is pretty the height you know who I have
not seen in a very very long time so
let's just see if Zedd can get a good
view of her hopefully she's not gonna
disappear from us okay we have our rain
roof on so this is where it becomes a
little bit tricky now hyenas can mean
lots of things especially at this time
she's just crossed over into Torchwood's
and I am wondering if she is possibly
heading to the Dane I don't know
obviously I should just up ahead I'm
just gonna give her space hey pretty
you're so pretty oh I'm so happy to see
her honestly I know that sounds really
crazy but from going to see these hyenas
every single day to not seen them at all
I think this might be the best forest we
can follow her at the moment she has
gone on to Torchwood I will Emma can we
follow pretty onto Torchwood
I'm just checking to see if we can
follow her because if she leads us to
the den this is going to be a huge
moment for us
okay yeah I think we're gonna lose our
Oh
but you know this would make sense
actually I'm running through everything
in my head because this is where we've
been seeing the hyenas and we have
thought very very few corn we have
thought that she was acting sorry we're
back on Juma and sort of the southern
boundary latitude area but this would
make sense if they've actually things on
the southern boundary of Torchwood area
ah
the mystery is slowly unraveling so that
wasn't the best sight thing we could
have ever given you but it was pretty a
hundred percent and it was just so
wonderful to see her again I'm just
keeping my eyes over here she was
walking and a rather fast pace hmm
okay well that brings us further ahead
in our mystery Emma has just said we can
go into Torchwood but I have lost sight
of her okay
let's see if we can find her again
Chrissy please come back
now she wandered off this way this is
the only the only indication I have of
where she may be so save is also looking
out for her because it's gonna be a good
moment if we are able to locate a stain
once and for all
Linda's in woohoo yes I agree
whoo-hoo that's it be oh I just told
fabulous the ground is very uneven here
yes Linda woohoo that would be some
woman so what I'm scanning for it's
obviously pretty herself but potential
Tara might moans because I don't think
they're far into Torchwood because of
where we've been seeing them and where
we've been seeing tracks I think they
could just be on the boundary here and
that's there's a big termite mound over
here and that's why we've been thinking
that they have potentially moved back to
Juma this would make a lot of sense can
you see her said no yeah yeah we're
gonna go and check out this termite man
this one looks a bit too small for a
hyena Dane
yes that's really good because we've
been talking about it every day and it's
honestly not for our lack of try and
myself Jamie said Davi we've all been
really really looking for potential
downsides this mind is definitely big
enough but I don't see any hyenas pretty
where did you go
Lauren is asking has anyone seen or
heard of June's babies okay a little bit
no I don't believe they have since our
hyenas have disappeared from us we have
had very very very little information we
did get information that we were on
little gallery and we actually got a
photo it's always good to get photo to
make sure you've got that evidence and
we saw Corki and we saw pretty with the
cups so we know that they definitely
moved but that's the only information
we've had I've not heard anything about
Juden so sorry Lauren but it would be
great news if we were able to locate her
and of course there are being Cubs okay
I'm a bit stuck on where to look now cuz
Chrissy has disappeared but we me check
this area know what said okay okay okay
okay sab sees something oh yeah yeah I
see her well spotted said yeah okay
we've got her again she's coming towards
us so we're just gonna pull up and
actually see where she goes
can I stop here okay right let's take a
look at her it is so good to see you
again very recognizable from that notch
in her left ear the color the color of
her coat is very fun it's very orange
it's quite actually unusual compared to
the rest of the hyenas but it is
definitely her for those that do know
pretty she's actually taking us in a
circle here so we're gonna keep
following her just in case she takes us
to this den this is normally the time of
day where actually the hyenas do go back
to the day now obviously it's not your
normal kind of day weather-wise yes it's
not your normal day weather-wise but she
is hoping what are you doing you having
a little scratch barefoot so if I always
stay with pretty here we are gonna send
you across to James who I think has an
ego
hello everybody here we are with a
juvenile data lien now if you look
carefully at its head I think he looks a
little bit like he's wearing chainmail
you know those pictures you see ever
night just before he puts his helmet on
I think that's what he looks like a bit
ridiculous not to go into battle now
he's sitting here because we closed to
go Chavez kill we've gone past it again
we've had a look she's not there we are
still kind of perusing the area seeing
if she's around I suspect that the
reason there are no other vehicles
anywhere near us at the moment is
because they have been looking here and
she hasn't pitched up unfortunately we
were car gonna keep going foot because
of course we do have a TV show coming up
and it would be rather good that we had
if we had some will leopard content for
it
marika yes certainly the new Cubs would
have started eating meat absolutely in
fact they'll be starting to wean now at
12 weeks old and so well one would
expect them to be coming to the kill and
I'm just wondering if she hasn't gone
off to fetch them because that would be
very very special no it's always
difficult to tell you know what there's
another rep to calling just off to the
left-hand side of where we're sitting
and it's making a big noise and I think
what we need to do is go and look there
because I think it's alarm calling and
something is just in that direction
there let's go and see David's just
putting our picnic away he was in charge
of our picnic and well he's obviously on
rations for some reason I'm not sure why
anyway let's go back to Lauren she is
God's pretty which is very exciting and
hopefully she will lead Lauren toward
end there's the other bird
so we are still following pretty were
just staying far back don't worry and
she's actually just picked up the piece
it's almost as if she years I must say
live live and her beautiful voice and
she decides to run we can still see her
though yeah she's still up ahead and
actually we were just saying it might
not be the same she's taking us to it
could potentially be a carcass or a kill
or anything else but she's definitely on
a mission so it's completely worth
following our so I'm just trying to keep
my eyes on her as much as possible at
the minute I don't want her to escape us
you just sit a complete circle
he's having a little sniff around I'm
just gonna turn on ya tell you beautiful
girl where you go in she's really on a
mission okay it's time to follow her
again I cannot explain to you how happy
it would make me if we fund this thing I
cannot begin to tell you I would love to
know how all the Cubs are doing and how
everybody's doing
jenna is asking can pretty be pregnant
if she still has Cubs I think at this
stage her Cubs are gonna be about four
to five months maximum so I think
they're far too young for pretty to be
pregnant just yet okay sorry I'm just
need to try and get ready for my eye on
her she crossed over okay let's see if
we can find her so no luck with the Dame
still she may take us somewhere hyenas
are never just wandering they're always
on a mission somewhere so they could
potentially take us to a leopard sure
I'm sure and she went in here
No pretty where have you gone
well at least we got a glimpse of her no
I'm pretty is very accustomed to cars or
there's lots of hyena tracks going down
here as well yeah she did definitely
crossover and you know there's lots of
termite mounds here too so kid
potentially also yeah and the rain
started again fabulous it's been a
rather wet day for me but this time I'm
more prepared okay so she okay forget
what I was just about to say pretty is
up ahead on the road right walking along
the road and it's ideal when animals
walk on the road because you can track
them you can see them and it's easy to
follow them it gets tricky when they
start going through all the vegetation
now we're driving right to into the rain
which is joyous
Gudivada says oh she's claiming up an
embankment now and disappeared
completely going and we can't get across
because there's a rather large log in
front okay we're gonna turn around she's
in there somewhere
and see if we can keep trying to follow
ever pretty girl
Here I am and it is very exciting
because in front of me is all the cups
lionesses and the big male and I think
they are drinking they are looking for
water right here so I'm gonna go and
pack and then wait for them to come
close it is quite a sight I'm hoping to
give you the picture right now just hold
on there don't go anywhere I'm looking
for the big male easier he's drinking
yeah he's here but yeah he's yeah he's
drinking
yes is having drinking some water and
the others are coming here for a drink
also so we just gonna wait it here and
see what's gonna happen he's right there
this is one of the older new pi ik males
he's the one meal with one testicle
sorry for the language but that's the
truth he's got only one and we know him
for that yeah the other one has got two
that are joined and we know them for
both for that they are two quite rather
very unique meals and you know he's
there and he's gonna be there for the
next like two three minutes lapping
water it's rather hard they're using
just a time to drink so they'll go on
and on and on and on and on and some
more are coming so just wait they're
coming can you see them no they've
headed out sorry
and actually I can see some young cups
very young cups I don't know how many I
see one
yeah the quite a distance will show you
those yeah let's stick with this guy
who's drinking fast yeah this is you
know fully grown male he's got his eyes
closed and he's enjoying his drink he's
been out in the open the whole day I'm
so you know a drink of cold water is a
very quenching and he will drink you
know for a bit longer
yeah can't wait to see him stand up and
you can see the size of him he is a
massive male so just chill there don't
go anywhere
remember this is coming to you live
nattie you see they have so many flies i
think being out in the open in the day
does give out an order
and so these flies are attracted to that
and that's why they are there and also
you know the owls who very thirsty so
they're trying to suck whatever they can
get from the skin of the of the lion
when he's lying down in the grass he
does maybe produce some sweat or you
know gets the ground wet so they come
and get that moisture from you know the
hairs from the skin that's why they've
got all these flies in the face I would
say they come to you know it off bits of
meat that I've been left there may be
blood he's going on he's still drinking
he is very busy yeah I saw him from a
distance heading this way we do you know
exactly what he was going to do but this
is what he's doing
yeah I still lapping the water yeah just
gonna reposition slightly like you know
so we can have a better view when he
stands up yeah he's gonna be we gonna be
I think that's better over there yeah
sorry it's right into the Sun but I hope
you're getting a good picture this is
the best we can do
it's wet in front of me and and you hear
how is lapping the water
everything he does is in you know big
quantities it's a lot he drinks a lot
when he gets it because he doesn't know
that seems let's see him stand up oh I
thought you're gonna stand up and look
at me or look at him Wow beautiful look
at him you can see he's headed out it's
hard enough
is he gonna lie there and wait and then
drink some more later well look at how
fool he is and how big his
you know he's a good 220 kilos blue yeah
see how hard it is you didn't know he
was there to know that he's there now
he's gonna rest there maybe after
another 1 hour then he's gonna come back
and take some more then head out and
then he will go for maybe even 10 days
without drinking even more if he's
forced to and then you know when he
finds where there's water again he's
gonna drink beautiful he's a good 200
kilos which is around 400 pounds and
there are two of them that two of them
at the moment I see one I'm thinking the
other one is not very far because about
five days ago I saw them and they were
not far off from this area so I'm
thinking the other guy is not very far
off he's much bigger than his other
brother he's got our document than his
brother and the only way we identify him
is the way I told you alia and this II
know he's got nothing to worry about
he's so healthy
yeah he's super it's just one of those
big lines that you know everybody want
to see see how he's hidden there he's
gone plume and you cannot see him he's
hiding there you cannot believe there is
a big male ion they're just you know
there it's there but we cannot see it
yeah he's they actually yeah even James
couldn't find him with a super powerful
lens see this tummy breathing
yeah I'm gonna leave him let me send you
to Jamie and see what he sees what he's
looking for
alrights have a look at the miserable
miserable view in a second I'll get you
there hold on
it's back we had a bit about an hour's
worth of respite from the weather let me
tilt this up a bit that didn't work out
so well but knit mud you can you can get
the idea with a nice artistic dead tree
sorry my bad take my foot off the brake
here comes the rain again amazing how it
gives everything an extra layered look
wish there was a lipid in it somewhere
there is a lipid somewhere there can
guarantee it we just haven't found it
I'm really excited though for Lauren I
really really am I hope she succeeds in
her mission of following pretty it is
not fun following a hyena off-road for a
couple of reasons one they don't they're
not used to it
nobody really follows them so they get a
bit disconcerted and - they don't stroll
hyenas trot oh dear Craig I can still
hear the generator which means we are
definitely not getting power back in the
course of the next few hours it is
Sunday the power went out
I don't know sometime around 3:00 4:00
in the morning this morning and we
haven't seen back since and the
generator of course keeps our broadcast
stuff going but very little else so none
of us have had showers well I haven't
had a shower Craig managed this morning
I haven't had a shower because where I
am and Inga's the water pump runs off
the electricity so unless I wanted to
try and shower in a drip it was no way
it was going to work
could be worse though it could be poor
Tristan whose neck is frozen in a spasm
you woke up that way so we are powerless
in many senses of the word powerless to
find leopards powerless in general
luckily the Mara team has been honoured
from the start I miss you can i well
very good we got some difference apart
from the Lions we got some hornbill here
Joshua he's coming to us where we are
I'm saying the he because I'm looking at
the water below his neck and there's no
blue in it if it's a female then what
you see there would be little smaller
than that ballooning thingy below his
neck build smaller and there'd be a bit
of polish bluish colors who cause
doesn't have that this is definitely a
male and this is the solvent ground
hornbill and either is tearing apart
some poo of an elephant and it's
definitely looking for either beetles or
something like that in it to feed on
it's the largest hornbill we got in
Africa and at the size of that big
because we know the digestion of
elephants is not very good and very
efficient on what they eat we have known
them to eat Beto's they come out through
the system still alive and I'm sure that
is what he is looking for you know a
cleaner beak well done you better and
interesting anytime even when they seem
to have shut their beak there's a huge
open space there like the open bill
stocks monogamous bats always growing a
male and a female together
Allisyn have young ones remember your
comments or questions are very welcome
hashtag safari live on twitter
outsi looking at the IUCN Red List this
bad have been listed as quite vulnerable
or very and danger I'm talking of losing
a lot of the habitat because you have
seen people logging and bringing down
huge trees which they need to nest on
they prefer very long very solid and big
trees to build their nests and very old
trees at the same time and unfortunately
the same trees are very good for
furniture or for constructions of
buildings very clean but I would say it
eaten as much as to get a lot of junk on
the big it very quickly cleans himself
where is your partner because I would
guess you're not alone as I said very
sure to see them on their own and my
guess is he is only swallowing some kind
of insects not the poo of the le very
clean very good table manners and I'm
sure he's using his fits like a napkin
just to clean his mouth and how killing
it's even better I better toughen up
King I think the first one was much
softer
this shows how clean you are mr. Han do
I'm surprised you alone and I would
guess you could be having whoops tend to
have a public course I agree with you
they look very intelligent look at how
he was fitting he opens up the dung and
he knows exactly where to get the
beetles because definitely the beaters
be right inside the dung feels very
quickly but it of course in the process
goes hider of swallowing the insect
think that a bit of dung you know in you
know on his beak he definitely sees his
toes to clean himself and what does not
come out she's a small low bushes or
plants to even clean himself better
whoops
why did you jump that what do you see
something maybe he was not very shoe off
the other challenge about these hoglets
once they mate and the females they'd
laid eggs at 6:00 about three years or
so to raise their young ones and they
have what you call corporates breeding
while you get other members of the
family racing the young ones trees how
big the wingspan of this humble of gas
could be anything about three feet three
feet when they all spread out so that's
pretty large and as much as the you see
him on the ground Trish they do fly the
new fly and they spend most of the time
on the ground and as a result that
suggests the name ground hornbills and
once they're done was the fool you see
them in flight and have a white feathers
or white wings or white windows win
flight and they spend the rest of the
night on top of trees let me see we can
turn around and find out where he's
hiding
and as I'm turning around
we'll take you back to Isaac quit his
lanes
yes I am back to the caucus and as I
told you there is still plenty of meat
along the chest along the neck and they
knew that and they're back to claim that
last bit of meat we just arrived here as
you can tell they're still arriving all
the five females are within the male
I've left him drinking water at a
distance
and the three older Cubs are here it
looks like the majority of the pride is
here the only missing is one male and
the four little cubbies the new ones
they additional to the sausage tree
pride they just walked quite a distance
from where they are I thought we were
gonna go for a drink
but they change their mind sometimes
it's really hard even being very
experienced to you know pick up exactly
what so that'll happen in the next
minute because they really look like
they wanted to go drink then all of a
sudden they change the direction they
were headed and they headed here we just
arrived to where this caucus lucky you
say if you know they will not get sick I
would say they have amazing bacterial
bacteria in their tummies so everything
will be all the jumps will be destroyed
I've never seen a sick lion from eating
a carcass I have seen a sick lion from
infections wounds but not you know like
from internal disease that is another
female coming from a distance so looks
like they're all here yes so you know
they won't
it hasn't rotted because you can imagine
it's only been around how many hours I
think maybe even 20 hours it's not 24 so
you know when they open it up this is
when you're gonna see that it's still
gonna be very fresh very red
Megan you are see if it's normal for
females to God a caucus yes if the
females are not if the males are not
present females will take turns to guard
the caucus so it is normal for them to
do this and especially where there is no
shade
when this shade when they put in in the
shade actually very few animals will
come and fly underneath the tree because
they are just afraid of the big canopy
of the tree they prefer open areas where
they can take off quite fast especially
vultures so they will avoid it in this
areas like this they will try and you
know guard it as much as possible I
don't know why they are all looking
around this really you know the young
ones are looking around I don't know
what they're looking I think they are
looking at the vultures in the trees
that's what they're looking at that's
what I would say because there's nothing
to worry them these are the three cubs
but I young the two to the right are
five months they want to the left is
four months he was born with his brother
but unfortunately died at a very young
age I hope this young guy makes it so
that you know that Lita is not lost
immortality rate is still quite high
until they're about two years lions so
even now there is no like insurance that
he was alive to adulthood
there is another lioness there and I
don't know what she is looking at
I'm gonna take my binoculars and have a
look you know she is keenly looking down
there a note he sees he sees they have
amazing eyesight and sometimes I have to
use my binoculars to actually see what
they are looking at this moment I don't
see but that intense look tells me you
know there could be something that no he
had seen but in the sea you can tell she
is losing interest by blinking
you know breathing with his mouth open
yes I'll send you to Tristan who's got
an intense looking eagle enjoy it well
that was a very hectic following of
pretty but we are glad you're back with
us we lost some communications and of
course we lost pretty but we have found
a pretty bird now this is probably one
of the largest birds of prey I have seen
out here and I want to see if any of you
can actually identify which bird this is
because I have not came across this bird
on a live drive before it is absolutely
massive scepters gonna give you a bit of
a wider view of it and you can really
see how big that bird is just on top of
the dead tree here so let's see if any
of you can tell us exactly what it is
he's in the hash tag Safari live so
while we wait on some of your amazing
answers we will update you pretty just
completely disappeared from us but we
believe she was really on the Seine of
some sort of carcass the way she was
behaving it was becoming quite erratic
in France that she was sniffing
constantly and she was kind of moving in
loops so we were really thinking what is
she doing is she trying to evade us and
obviously she wasn't she was just
picking up on the same moving around
getting a sniff maybe going this way
thinking normal no more was coming from
the east it's coming from the West
and she left us saw indeed at least I
can have an update on the mystery of the
hyenas I do believe they could be on the
southern boundary or torch that is where
we are giving a lot of a you know
activity so that's our next mission for
the next few days tomorrow morning I
probably will follow up on that and see
if we can possibly locate this den now I
wonder if any of you have mana
to ID this bird for us sean has seen a
Marshall eco okay I wonder if we have
any other before we dive into it it is a
very very big and of course we also have
the Egyptian geese here now we did see
them live the other day and you can see
there's four little Gosselin's how cute
are they but unfortunately it is sad to
see there was six the other day and
neither only appears to be four so I
hate to think what might have happened
that these two geese have lost have lost
and I'm just turning to games i video
done they have obviously lost on the
coastline so someone suggested a
juvenile fish eagle I can't remember
what the labels so that's two
suggestions we have a Marshall eco and
we have a juvenile fish eco David
suggests eats the juvenile fish you go
well it is very difficult it's a really
not the easiest bird that I've came
across to identify but I do believe we
have here a juvenile martial eagle so
you can see it's quite fluffy it looks
like it needs a good brush with a
hairbrush or a comb and that's usually
it was gonna miss hat which is what's
attacking it I can't quite catch what it
is oh can you hear that
look at the waves just groping on with
his claws Palin's
I'm not able to get quite a look at
exactly which bird is attacking it but
it's not happy this juvenile martial
Eagle is here lots of bird noise ease I
think another bird flew off yes
hey mom glad you came here that is a
whole lot of noise and alarm calling
well I think it's worth staying in this
area for a little while and look see
exactly what is going on well that other
bird that was doing the attacking has
disappeared but it was very small I'm
not sure I would be so brave enough to
go for this juvenile martial Eagle it's
amazing how strong the smaller birds can
be is like they have no fear we
regularly see small birds especially
drongos attacking the much larger birds
of prey so before that attack I was
saying how fluffy this bird can looks
looks like it has its juvenile plumage
and it looks like it needs a good brush
child of the universe is asking why does
the bird not go for the Gosselin's and
that that is a good question it could
potentially do that you see the size of
the bird in the size of the talons and
they are but obviously the parents are
with the Gosselin's here and they are
definitely missing too because I could
have easily have been from a bird of
prey so for these two adult Egyptian
geese it's not gonna be easy to protect
these little cousins they are very
vulnerable and every time we drive past
this little waterhole they're just going
across from side to side to side to side
with the adults so Egyptian keys can be
very violent they can be very ferocious
so I imagine this juvenile martial ego
will take on quite a bit sin from these
two Egyptian geese if it was to try and
calm down and get a little Gosselin they
would be fiercely protected by the
adults and it could also potentially not
be so hungry right now but it is just
sitting there watching over the
waterhole and it blends in really well
with the surroundings how adorable are
these little coastlands oh they're so
cute and of course the survival rate is
not so high not many of them maybe not
all of them will make it oh was this the
attacker mm-hmm so we're having a bit of
a bird party over here seems to be
looking for something in the water and
the alarm calls are still going
hmm they like have walked in on a bird
event Oh aren't you just stunning
what a beautiful beautiful world of free
blend in very well with that tree there
I'm glad you're all enjoying seeing this
lovely bird it was a perfect find after
the bumbling around after pretty it was
not the easiest thing to follow hard but
at least we've had a lead on where they
could potentially be so of course it is
time to begin wrapping up today's drive
and we do apologize for all the
technical difficulties that we did have
today but stay tuned with us bear with
us and join us tomorrow for the sunrise
safai at the normal time of 5:00 a.m.
thank you for all your comments and
questions from all of us here at safari
life
[Music]